[Music]
the marvelous missus Mazal recently
debuted its marvelous second season on
Amazon the show is known for its
rapid-fire quips and outstanding
ensemble casts but one thing you might
not actually pay attention to its
cinematography cinematographers
determine how a scene is shot and how
it's lit the second season of mrs. Mazal
starts with this long winding shot
through a switchboard room
we got a behind-the-scenes look at how
the Mazal team pulled off this dizzying
shot first of all we should talk about
long takes an early example comes from
Orson Welles Touch of Evil in 1958 the
film's opening shot goes uninterrupted
for about three minutes and 20 seconds
Alfonso Cuaron's children of men
involves multiple breathtaking one-shot
action scenes then in 2014 Alejandro
Gonzales and Yuri - made the entirety of
Birdman look like one long shot the one
from the marvelous mrs. Mazal comes at
the opening of season 2 the scene is set
at the fictitious department store where
midge Mazal played by Rachel Brosnahan
works I think in general we don't do a
lot of cutting on the show and there's a
lot of one-take scenes dialogue scenes
so it's part of our language for the
show in general that's em David Mullin
he's the show's director of photography
pulling off something like this
naturally involves a lot of planning
beforehand they discussed this one
single shot for about three or four
weeks before actually filming it Mullin
had to figure out what kind of camera to
use if he needed any special lenses and
if he was going to actually have to put
a camera inside a mail slot a CGI shot
of the piece of mail falling through the
slot helped them more easily capture the
shot while still giving a look of a
continuous take the next part was all
real the team waited for their cue to
enter trailing the mailman at the exact
moment he walked into the switchboard
room while they originally considered
using a more complicated cable system
they settled on Steadicam
this allowed them to tilt the camera
first from above the cart and then
behind the mailman into the room while
the camera remained relatively still
things got even tougher once they
actually enter the switchboard room
while cameras can move fast Mullen says
every shot is limited by the speed of
the human behind them plus they were
working in a tight space that had to fit
12 actors at least two crew members and
all the equipment and we turned into the
room and this was the part when we had
to decide whether to go on the outside
of the inside of this row they won with
the more difficult choice
inside the row the space was so tight
that the actresses had to move their
heads back so they wouldn't get hit in
the face at the same time the camera
couldn't capture that they were leaning
back so it was just a matter of timing
just as we're passing their nose
essentially they could start to lean out
of the way once there the camera ends up
focused fully on image except she
doesn't just sit still just to launch
across the room in a rolling chair to
take the call the camera crew had to
follow her there a space Mullen
approximates to be about five feet
across while circling around Mitch the
camera sometimes would have to end up in
a place where one of the women was
sitting in order to properly capture the
shot so if they wrapped around her that
actor would be blocking the shot that
meant the extras constantly had to
scramble around as the camera went
diagonally across the room so we would
always see them in the right position
this is somewhat visible in the final
scene but at times Brosnahan scene
partners had to physically push her
around so she ended up in the right spot
nailing this involved a lot of
rehearsing and teamwork between the
actors in the camera crew
there were some physical barriers such
as a file cabinet right here and a wall
right here it left them with very little
room to circle around as you can see
here the camera just makes it past all
their heads the shot ends once midge
finishes the call she turns around to
the group and the camera immediately
cuts to a reverse angle then the camera
goes back out the room and down the hall
for those of you at home timing in about
one minute and 17 seconds passes between
the letter making it down the mail slot
and mids turning to the group the shot
proved to be a perfect entry back into
the shows whimsical world the idea to
shoot the scene this way came from Mazal
creator Amy sherman-palladino who also
directed this episode a lot of these
super complicated shots are own or
imagination she's a formerly a dancer
and she loves movements with extras and
the camera that feel like a dance number
so she imagined the switchboard scene
which as you can imagine people sitting
in a console would not lend itself to
much movement but she wanted Mitch to
sort of slide quickly back and forth in
the rolling chair and the camera to keep
up with her and the camera to be able to
move among these women and these cables
and these these hand switching switches
while comedy is a genre that people
don't always think about when they
consider technical innovation there's no
way you could look away from the
dazzling visuals of the marvelous mrs.
nasal
[Music]
[Applause]